from air show
to test flights in extreme cold weather
china's state-owned aircraft
manufacturer comac
has been ramping up the development of
its c919 passenger jet to compete with
boeing and airbus
c919 is an important part of china's
national development strategy
though the project is years behind
schedule beijing is moving ahead with
big plans
at a time when the coronavirus has
upended the aviation industry around the
world
last december comac began the process of
certifying the c919 for commercial
operations
the large economies have not recovered
as quickly as china
and therefore china's likely share
of future commercial aviation growth is
going to be somewhat higher
eventually the government hopes the c919
will become the main carrier in the
world's biggest commercial aviation
market
but can it succeed chinese president xi
jinping has had an aviation dream since
he took office in 2012
to build the country's first commercial
civilian airliner
[ __ ]
for the past two decades airbus and
boeing have benefited from china's
fast-growing commercial aviation market
airbus built an assembly plant in china
in 2008
and before the pandemic a quarter of all
boeing planes that came off the assembly
line went to china
and the demand isn't going away any time
soon according to boeing's latest market
outlook from this past october
it expects china to buy more than 8 400
new airplanes over the next 20 years
with the market valued at a total of
more than 1.7 trillion dollars
there is a very good economic reason for
china to want to
build its own aircraft and that is
so that it can fill that market and save
a huge amount of money
timothy heath is a defense researcher
who's been studying china's national
aviation strategy for more than 15 years
the problem is that due to his lack of
experience
there's a very steep learning curve for
instance compared to boeing's more than
100 years of experience
china started exploring commercial
aviation in the 1970s
so to catch up the chinese government
has been focused on comac
which was only established in 2008.
according to the u.s think tank the
center for strategic and international
studies
since comac's early days it has received
somewhere between 49 and 72 billion
dollars in government aid
far more than the 22 billion dollars
that erebus has received from european
governments according to the world trade
organization
heath says while support from beijing
has helped build successful home-grown
companies in industries including 5g and
artificial intelligence
it'll take more than money to help the
c919 take off
the difference is that civilian airliner
manufacturers
is an order of magnitude more difficult
than
cell phone technology in handheld
consumer electronics
that's because building a commercial
aircraft requires hundreds of thousands
of components
there are individual components which
are ridiculously difficult to make
because you have to make them perfectly
and they have to work at 35 000 feet in
the air
for hour upon hour land gas up and do it
again
with no problems scott kennedy is a
senior advisor at the center for
strategic and international studies
the nonprofit policy research
organization receives part of its
funding from some governments and
corporations including boeing
kennedy has been analyzing china's
industrial policy for more than 25 years
most of the parts that chinese make are
in the interior
or for elements of the body or the doors
so the chinese components are relevant
to the plane
but they're not central to the plane's
ability to fly
the more complex parts are imported
china depends
almost entirely on the us and europe
for the components that go into the
plane from the engine to the avionics
to the materials to most of what's
inside the plane even
according to kennedy's analysis only 14
key suppliers are from china
and half of them are joint ventures with
foreign companies
and these joint ventures are one
important part of comex plans to advance
technologically
the chinese have actually required
support suppliers to transfer technology
in many cases
that means the chinese are absorbing
technology and they're
they're learning how to make some of the
components
but for years western manufacturers have
acted to protect their ip by only
supplying old technology
it's already an obsolete plane because
you've been using the oldest
most out of date technology because the
companies don't want to share and give
away their most cutting edge
valuable technology still the trump
administration kept an eye on joint
ventures
concern that forced technology transfers
could allow china to break into the
global jet engine market and undermine
u.s businesses
in a world of heightened diplomatic
tensions
that are growing more severe by the day
one has to question whether
those diplomatic tensions could
eventually
bring a project like the c919 to a halt
for instance in early january the trump
administration added comac to a list of
companies it says support china's
military this blacklist could ban
americans from supplying the plane
manufacturer comac didn't respond to a
request for comment
it's uncertain how political tensions
will change during the biden
administration
but kennedy says the success of comac
will take longer than one presidential
term
despite all of the state support and the
history of china overcoming previous
technological hurdles
i still think that we're no we're no
closer than a decade away from comac
being
a serious competitor to boeing or airbus
until then china will need to rely on
their jets but when the c919 is ready
it potentially has a guaranteed market
at home since beijing could order its
state-owned
airlines to buy the plane in large
numbers according to kennedy's analysis
comac already had more than 1 000 orders
by the end of 2020.
these orders have been on the books for
a long time
but those numbers on orders are really
smoke and mirrors until they really can
prove that they can deliver
and service planes on a regular basis